This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Today's show is about something so tiny and unremarkable and ubiquitous that I can't quite believe we're doing a whole episode about it. It's sand. The tiny grains of a rotted rock that we sculpt into castles at the beach. Sand might not seem like a topic worthy of our attention, but Vince Buyser wrote a whole book about sand. It's called The World in a Grain, and I promise you, it is fascinating. Here's my conversation with Vince, all about sand, and how it transformed our civilization. You know, when you were spending a few years on this,
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。今天的节目要聊的是一种非常微小、毫不起眼却又无处不在的东西，以至于我简直不敢相信我们要为它做整整一期节目。这就是沙子。那些被我们塑造成海滩城堡的、风化岩石的微小颗粒。沙子看起来可能不是一个值得我们关注的话题，但文斯·拜泽尔写了一整本关于沙子的书。书名叫《沙粒中的世界》，我向你保证，它非常迷人。以下是我与文斯的对话，全部关于沙子，以及它如何改变了我们的文明。你知道的，当你花了好几年时间研究这个时，
I imagine, you told someone you were working on a book about sand. What was the look on their face? And how did you explain this to them to make them understand how cool and important and you told someone you were working on a book about sand. What was the look on their face? And how did you explain this to them to make them understand how cool and important this subject is? So every single time I would get this look that was just like, huh?
我猜，你告诉别人你正在写一本关于沙子书的时候。他们脸上是什么表情？你是如何向他们解释，让他们明白这个主题是多么酷、多么重要，而你告诉别人你正在写一本关于沙子书的时候。他们脸上是什么表情？你是如何向他们解释，让他们明白这个主题是多么酷、多么重要？所以每次我都会得到这样的表情，就好像是，啊？
Like, why am I trapped? You know, why am I trapped in a conversation with this person who's so obsessed with the most boring thing on earth. And basically my comeback was, why would I write a book about what sounds like the most boring thing in the world? And the reason is because sand is actually the most important solid substance on earth. It's the literal foundation of modern civilization. Yeah.
就像，我为什么被困住了？你知道的，为什么我会被困在与这个人的对话中，他对地球上最无聊的事情如此着迷。基本上我的回应是，我为什么要去写一本听起来像是世界上最无聊的事情的书呢？原因其实是，沙子实际上是地球上最重要的固体物质。它是现代文明的字面基石。是的。
And so how do we use sand in our daily lives? So basically, if you look around you right now, I don't know where you are, but chances are excellent, no matter what kind of building or office or room you're sitting in, the floor underneath you, the walls around, the ceiling overhead, the building you're sitting in is probably made at least partly out of concrete, just like every shopping mall, every apartment building, every office tower, everywhere in the world from Beijing to Lagos is made out of concrete. And what is concrete? Concrete is nothing but sand and gravel that's been stuck together. The roads that connect all those buildings also made out of sand. They're either concrete or
那么我们在日常生活中是如何使用沙子的呢？所以基本上，如果你现在环顾四周，我不知道你在哪里，但极有可能的是，无论你坐在什么样的大楼、办公室或房间里，你脚下的地板、周围的墙壁、头顶的天花板，你所坐的大楼可能至少有一部分是混凝土做的，就像世界上从北京到拉各斯的所有购物中心、每一栋公寓楼、每一座办公大楼一样，都是用混凝土建造的。什么是混凝土？混凝土其实就是粘合在一起的沙子和碎石。连接所有这些建筑的道路也是用沙子建造的。它们要么是混凝土，要么是
they're asphalt. Asphalt is also just sand that's been glued together. The windows in every one of those buildings are made of sand. Glass is nothing but sand that's been melted down. The silicon chips that power our computers, our cell phones, also made from sand. In other words, without sand, no modern civilization. And here's the real kicker. We are starting to run out. How is that possible? It feels like there is so much sand in the world. There is a lot of sand in the world.
它们是沥青。沥青也只是用胶水粘合在一起的沙子。那些建筑里的每一扇窗户都是用沙子做的。玻璃不过是融化的沙子。驱动我们电脑、手机的硅芯片，也是用沙子制造的。换句话说，没有沙子，就没有现代文明。最关键的是。我们开始快用完了。这怎么可能？感觉世界上有那么多的沙子。世界上确实有很多沙子。
It's actually the most abundant thing on the planet. But we are also using way more of it than ever before in human history. We use more sand than any other natural resource in the world, except for air and water. We use about 50 billion tons of the stuff every single year, which is enough to cover the entire state of California. Why don't we just go to the Sahara and take all the sand there? Right, great question. So there is, of course, you know, practically infinite amounts of sand in the desert. The problem is that sand is pretty much useless to us. The reason is that desert sand has a different shape. The actual grains are shaped differently than the sand grains that you find at the bottom of rivers or on beaches.
它实际上是地球上最丰富的物质。但我们在整个人类历史上也是前所未有地大量消耗它。除了空气和水，我们使用的沙子比世界上任何其他自然资源都要多。我们每年使用大约 50 亿吨这种东西，这足以覆盖整个加利福尼亚州。为什么我们不去撒哈拉沙漠把那里的沙子都拿走呢？没错，问得好。所以，当然了，沙漠里有几乎无限量的沙子。问题是，这些沙子对我们来说几乎毫无用处。原因在于沙漠沙的形状不同。实际颗粒的形状与你在河底或海滩上找到的沙粒不同。
It's been eroded by wind rather than water over thousands and millions of years. And as a result, the grains are a lot rounder and smoother than the grains that you find at the bottom of rivers. So the number one thing that we need sand for by far is concrete. And that desert sand just doesn't lock together to form a strong, stable structure that you need for concrete. It's like the difference between trying to build something out of a stack of little marbles as opposed to a stack of little bricks. So all that desert sand pretty much useless.
数千乃至数百万年来，它们是被风而不是水侵蚀的。因此，这些颗粒比你在河底找到的沙粒要圆得多、光滑得多。所以，我们需要沙子的头号用途绝对是混凝土。而那些沙漠沙根本无法粘合在一起，无法形成混凝土所需的坚固、稳定的结构。这就像试图用一堆小弹珠而不是一堆小砖块来建造东西的区别。所以所有那些沙漠沙基本上都毫无用处。
And so we have to get it from water-eroded sand that comes off of mountains and then accumulates in rivers and things like that. That's the sand we need. Exactly. Exactly. And this is why it becomes such a problem, because when you're talking about extracting millions of tons of sand from the bottom of a lake or the bottom of a river, inevitably, we are doing tremendous environmental damage to get at that sand, ripping up riverbeds,
因此我们必须获取水侵蚀形成的沙子，这些沙子来自山脉，然后堆积在河流等地方。这才是我们需要的沙子。完全正确。完全正确。这就是为什么它会成为这样一个大问题，因为当你谈论从湖底或河底开采数百万吨沙子时，不可避免地，我们为了获取这些沙子会对环境造成巨大的破坏，撕裂河床，
stripping beaches, bare, stripping lake bottoms, bare, even digging it up out of the ocean, causing huge environmental damage all over the world. And in some places, supplies have gotten so tight that organized crime has actually moved into the industry. There's a black market in sand. So the demand for sand is so intense that it's actually leading to global conflict. It's true. There is so much demand for sand that in many places around the world, people are being imprisoned, tortured, and murdered by the hundreds over sand. And the violence is probably at its worst in India where they actually call them the sand mafia. but it's by no means the only place. In Kenya, in Indonesia, in Gambia, and many other places around the world, same kind of
剥光海滩，剥光湖底，甚至从海洋中掘取，对世界各地造成巨大的环境破坏。在某些地方，供应已经变得如此紧缺，以至于有组织犯罪实际上已经进入了这个行业。存在沙子黑市。因此，对沙子的需求如此强烈，以至于它实际上正在导致全球冲突。确实如此。对沙子的需求如此之大，以至于在世界上的许多地方，人们为了沙子而被成百上千地关进监狱、折磨和谋杀。这种暴力行为在印度可能最为严重，在那里他们实际上被称为沙子手枪党。但它绝不是唯一的地方。在肯尼亚、印度尼西亚、冈比亚以及世界上许多其他地方，同样的事情
thing. People are fighting and killing and dying over sand. Wow. And you've actually witnessed some of this. In India, you witnessed some of the crime associated with the San trade. Yeah, absolutely. This is what got me started on it. Is I just stumbled across an article about the murder
人们为了沙子而战、而杀戮、而死。哇。而且你实际上亲眼目睹了其中的一部分。在印度，你亲眼目睹了与沙子贸易相关的某些犯罪活动。是的，绝对的。这就是让我开始研究这个的原因。我只是偶然读到了一篇关于印度一名农民被谋杀的文章，
of a farmer in India, and what really caught my eye was that he had been killed over sand. And at that point, I was like most people. I'd never even thought about sand in my life. I'd never given it a second thought beyond like, oh, how am I going to get this sand out of my bathing suit, you know? But then I did a little more research and found that, especially in India, hundreds of people have been murdered over sand in the last few years.
真正引起我注意的是他是因为沙子而被杀的。在那之前，我和大多数人一样。我这辈子甚至都没想过沙子。除了像“我怎么把泳衣里的沙子弄出来”之外，我从来没有多想过，你知道吗？但后来我做了一些更多的研究，发现特别是在印度，过去几年里有数百人因沙子而被谋杀。
And I just thought that was the craziest thing I'd ever heard of. Like what in the world would make sand so valuable, so important that people would kill for it? And what I discovered was that it's sand is really the substance that we need to build cities out of and in India, as in most of the developing world, right? In China, in Nigeria, in Indonesia, you name it. We're building cities at a rate and at a speed that has never happened before in human history, which means we need huge amounts of sand.
我只是觉得这是我听过的最疯狂的事情。到底是什么让沙子变得如此宝贵、如此重要，以至于人们会为之杀戮？我发现的是，沙子确实是我们用来建造城市的物质，在印度，就像在大多数发展中国家一样，对吧？在中国、尼日利亚、印度尼西亚，随便哪个国家。我们以人类历史上从未有过的速度和速率在建设城市，这意味着我们需要大量的沙子。
Bizer says that today, massive amounts of sand are being moved around the world to fuel our growing appetite for glass and computer chips and asphalt. And over the years, sand has morphed from the literal ground beneath us into a commodity that's mined and refined and sold in a global marketplace. And while sand is the basis of so many different products, by far the biggest driver of the demand for sand is the production of concrete. Yeah, I mean, the story of concrete
拜泽尔说，如今，大量的沙子正在世界各地运送，以满足我们对玻璃、计算机芯片和沥青不断增长的需求。多年来，沙子已经从我们脚下的地面蜕变成了一种在全球市场上开采、精炼和销售的商品。虽然沙子是许多不同产品的基础，但迄今为止，对沙子需求最大的推动力是混凝土的生产。是的，我的意思是，混凝土的故事
is completely fascinating to me. I didn't know anything about it until I started the research for this book. You make concrete by taking sand and gravel and gluing them together with cement. And you can make cement in a few different ways, but basically you take a substance like lime and you bake it down and it turns into a powder.
对我来说完全充满吸引力。在开始研究这本书之前，我对它一无所知。制作混凝土的方法是将沙子和碎石与水泥粘合在一起。你可以通过几种不同的方式制造水泥，但基本上你是把石灰之类的物质拿来烘烤，它就会变成粉末。
And then when you mix that powder with water, it forms this paste that glues together all that sand and aggregate. But the real magic of it is it does more than just harden it actually forms a chemical bond between all those constituent parts, between the grains of sand and the gravel and the cement, which is why it's a great building material, right? It's really, really strong, it's really flexible. Anyway, so there are at least a couple
然后当你把这种粉末和水混合时，它就会形成一种浆糊，把所有的沙子和集料粘合在一起。但真正的魅力在于，它不仅仅是变硬，它实际上在所有这些组成部分之间、在沙粒、碎石和水泥之间形成了化学键，这就是为什么它是一种极好的建筑材料，对吧？它非常非常坚强，非常灵活。无论如何，所以至少有几对
three ancient civilizations that somehow figured out how to do this. The ancient Mayans used a form of concrete. Ancient Egyptians might have had a form of cement, but it was the Romans who really figured it out. And they actually used concrete in a really extensive way. They built roads out of it. They built aqueducts out of it, they built buildings out of it that are still standing today, like the pantheon in Rome has a concrete roof that's over
三个古代文明不知何故弄清楚了如何做到这一点。古代玛雅人使用了一种形式的混凝土。古埃及人可能有一种形式的水泥，但真正搞懂它的是罗马人。他们实际上在很大程度上使用了混凝土。他们用它建路，用它建引水渠，他们用它建造的建筑物至今仍然屹立不倒，比如罗马的万神殿就有一个混凝土屋顶，已经超过了
2,000 years old and it's still standing. So but here's the really bizarre twist. So the Romans figured out how to use concrete, used it to great effect for centuries, but then when the Roman Empire collapsed, the world sort of forgot how to make concrete, like the secret of concrete making kind of disappeared with the Roman Empire, and nobody built anything with concrete
有 2,000 年的历史了，而且它仍然屹立不倒。但是这里有一个非常离奇的转折。罗马人弄清楚了如何使用混凝土，并将其发挥了几个世纪的巨大作用，但随后当罗马帝国崩溃时，世界有点忘记了如何制作混凝土，就像制作混凝土的秘密随着罗马帝国一起消失了一样，没有人再用混凝土建造任何东西
for about 1,500 years. Quixote note, I love this story because I feel like it's this trope that you see in a lot of science fiction and fantasy that there's this ancient forgotten knowledge that holds the key to the future. But the thing about that trope is that it basically never exists in the real world, except for the story of concrete. Concrete is this amazing technology that gets completely forgotten for hundreds of years until the turn of the century, and then it re-emerges in a big way. And what really made the big change was an architect named Ernest Ransom, who is a British architect who had emigrated to the United States, set up shop in San Francisco. And he started tinkering around with cement and with concrete and figuring out different
大约有 1,500 年。有趣的是，我喜欢这个故事，因为我觉得这是你在许多科幻和奇幻作品中看到的一个老套路，即存在着某种掌握着未来钥匙的古老被遗忘的知识。但关于那个套路的事情是，它在现实世界中基本上是不存在的，除了混凝土的故事。混凝土是一项神奇的技术，被人们完全遗忘了几百年，直到世纪之交，然后它以巨大的方式重新出现。真正带来巨大改变的是一位名叫欧内斯特·兰森的建筑师，他是一位移居美国并在旧金山开店的英国建筑师。他开始摆弄水泥和混凝土，并琢磨出不同的
ways to, you know, to perfect the mix. And eventually, literally through tinkering in his backyard, he came up with the idea of reinforced concrete, which is concrete with those steel bars running through it. And that is, was Ernest Renzoam's great innovation. Basically, he found that by putting steel bars inside the concrete, the concrete would bind to those bars, and it would massively increase the tensile strength of the concrete. And he realized, wow, this is an incredible building material.
方法来，你知道的，完善配方。最终，通过在他后院的摸索，他想出了钢筋混凝土的概念，也就是内部穿插着钢筋的混凝土。这就是欧内斯特·兰森的伟大创新。基本上，他发现通过在混凝土内部放置钢筋，混凝土会与这些钢筋结合，并且会大大增加混凝土的抗拉强度。他意识到，哇，这是一种不可思议的建筑材料。
I can build the walls and the roofs of structures with this stuff. And it'll be cheap and it'll be strong. And holy smokes, this is the material of structures with this stuff, and it'll be cheap, and it'll be strong, and holy smokes, this is the material of the future. Thought Ernest Ransom. So he ran around the country trying to sell people on this idea, and basically people laughed at him. They were just like, why in the world would we even try this crazy new building material?
我可以用这东西建造建筑物的墙壁和屋顶。而且它很便宜，很坚固，天哪，这就是未来建筑物的材料，欧内斯特·兰森心想。于是他跑遍全国，试图向人们推销这个想法，基本上人们都嘲笑他。他们只是觉得，我们到底为什么要尝试这种疯狂的新建筑材料？
We build with stone, we build with bricks, we build with timber. These things have been tried and trusted for centuries. Why on earth would we take a chance on your wacky new idea? So he literally tries for years and years to sell people on this idea. And he gets a few commissions. He manages to build a few, get a few buildings built out of concrete in a couple of different places, two or three of them in San Francisco where he lives. So then comes 1906, the great San Francisco earthquake. Massive earthquake demolishes most of the city, followed by an enormous fire that basically
我们用石头建造，我们用砖块建造，我们用木材建造。这些东西已经经过了几个世纪的尝试和信赖。我们凭什么要去冒险尝试你那个古怪的新想法呢？所以他真的花了好几年时间向人们推销这个想法。他得到了一些委托。他设法建造了几处，在几个不同的地方用混凝土建造了几座建筑物，其中两三座在他居住的旧金山。然后是 1906 年，旧金山大地震。大地震摧毁了大部分城市，随之而来的是一场巨大火灾，基本上
burns San Francisco to the ground. But when the smoke clears and the dust is settled, some of the very few structures left standing in San Francisco are Ernest Ransom's reinforced concrete buildings. And that was a real turning point people all around the country. And in fact, all around the world looked at that and said, wow, that concrete stuff that really works.
把旧金山烧为平地。但当烟消云散、尘埃落定之后，旧金山少数几座屹立不倒的建筑之一就是欧内斯特·兰森的钢筋混凝土建筑。这是一个真正的转折点，全国各地的人们。事实上，全世界的人都看着那个并说，哇，那个混凝土东西真的管用。
You know, it whisted the earthquake, it whisted the fire, that stuff looks great. And in your book, you talk about how the new concrete industry that was developing really took advantage of these images from the San Francisco Fire and the concrete warehouses that survived is a way to argue that like, hey, check out this amazing new fire safe and earthquake proof material.
你知道，它经受住了地震，它经受住了火灾，那个东西看起来太棒了。在你的书中，你谈到了正在发展的全新混凝土行业是如何真正利用旧金山火灾中的这些影像以及幸存的混凝土仓库来作为争论的依据，就像是，嘿，来看看这个神奇的新防火防震材料。
Yeah, absolutely. They pushed themselves, you know, to builders, to engineers, to the general public in a really big way, advertising themselves really as the, you know, the material of the future. And in fact, it is. I mean, concrete is an amazingly versatile
是的，绝对的。他们向建筑商、工程师、广大公众大力推广自己，真正宣称自己是，你知道的，未来的材料。事实上，它确实是。我的意思是，混凝土是一种极其多功能且有用的材料。它非常容易使用。它很便宜而且真的很坚固，只要你建造得当。但你可以看到它。我的意思是，我当时查阅了大量的报纸。我的意思是，它几乎就像 90 年代的计算机和数字技术一样，
and useful material. It's very easy to work with. It's cheap and it's really strong, as long as you build it correctly. But you can see it. I mean, I sort of trawled through a lot of newspapers at the time. And I mean, it was almost like computers and digital technology in the 90s,
记者们对这些东西的报道方式就像是，哦，太棒了。科学彻底改变了我们的建造方式。我们将再也不用担心火灾，就像，你知道的，仿佛混凝土将解决人类已知的所有问题欣喜若狂。实际上，托马斯·爱迪生，他简直爱极了混凝土。他认为混凝土将会，你知道的，不仅将成为一种重要的建筑材料，而且基本上你可以用混凝土建造任何东西。他建造了几座完全由混凝土建造的房子，里面摆满了混凝土家具。他甚至建造了一架混凝土钢琴，他说这架钢琴在全国各地巡回演出。它确实允许建筑师们发挥
just the way that journalists were writing about this stuff is just like, oh, amazing. Science has revolutionized our way of building. Never more will we have to worry about fire, like, you know, as though concrete was going to solve every problem known to man. It was really people were just ecstatic over it. And in fact, Thomas Edison, he was just in love with concrete. He thought concrete was going to be, you know, was not only going to be an important building material, but that basically you could build anything out of concrete. He built several completely all concrete houses in which he furnished with concrete furniture. He even built a concrete piano that he said during around the country. It does actually allow architects to be
相当多的创造力，因为它可以被塑造成各种不同的形状。哦，绝对的，绝对的。我的意思是，看看古根海姆博物馆或悉尼歌剧院这样的结构，这些令人难以置信的奇思妙想和美丽的创造。你无法用砖块或石头做出那些东西。是的，没有混凝土是，除了使建造非常坚固、耐用的结构变得容易之外，
quite inventive because if it's ability to be shaped in all different kinds of ways. Oh absolutely, absolutely. I mean, look at things, structures like the Guggenheim or the Sydney Opera House, these incredibly fanciful and beautiful creations. You couldn't make those things out of bricks, or stone. Yeah, no concrete is, in addition to making it easy to build really strong, durable structures,
它使得建造世界上一些最美丽、最有创意的结构成为可能。更不用说最实用的了。我的意思是，就像这些巨大的水坝，在很多方面真正使现代美国西南部成为可能。所以我们在西方世界经历了20世纪建造大量混凝土的阶段。现在亚洲和非洲的城市正在经历巨大的增长。
it makes it possible to build some of the most beautiful and inventive structures in the world. Not to mention the most useful. I mean, things like these enormous dams that really made possible the modern Southwest in a lot of ways. And so we went through, in the Western world, we went through our phase of building a lot of concrete in the 20th century. And now there's a huge growth in cities in Asia and Africa.
那么，这就是今天大量沙子去向的地方吗？是的。所以我们，我的意思是，我们当然还在西方世界建造。我们这里仍然使用大量的沙子和大量的混凝土，但它完全相形见绌。我们在西方世界使用的数量与发展中国家正在发生的事情相比，完全是小巫见大巫。原因在于，第一，世界上的总人口越来越多，对吧？
So is that where a lot of the sand is going today? Yeah. So we, I mean, we're still building, of course, in the Western world. We still use a lot of sand and a lot of concrete here, but it is absolutely dwarfed. The amounts that we use in the Western world is absolutely dwarfed by what's going on in the developing world. And the reason for that is, number one, there's more and more people in the world all the time, right?
人口在增长。而且越来越多的人一直都在搬进城市。这和一百年前发生在这个国家的事情一样，人们离开农业乡村，离开农耕村庄，搬进城市。好吧，印度、中国和整个非洲正在发生同样的事情，但规模要大得多，速度要快得多，时间跨度也压缩得更厉害。为了让你有个概念，我们每年都在向世界增加相当于八个纽约市的规模。
Population is growing. And more and more of them are moving into cities all the time. The same thing that happened in this country a hundred years ago, people left the agricultural countryside, they left farming villages and moved into cities. Well, the same thing is happening in India and China, all over Africa, but on a much bigger scale and in a much faster rate and a much more compressed time frame. So to give you an idea, we're adding the equivalent of eight New York cities to the world every single year.
人口在增长。而且越来越多的人一直在搬进城市。就像这个国家一百年前发生的事情一样，人们离开农业乡村，离开农耕村庄，搬进了城市。同样的现象正在印度和中国以及整个非洲发生，但规模大得多，速度快得多，时间跨度也紧凑得多。为了让您有个概念，我们每年都在世界上增加相当于八个纽约市的规模。
Wow. Yeah, here's another way to think about it. The amount of concrete that we use every single year is enough to build a wall 88 feet high, 88 feet wide right around the equator, every year. And most of that is happening in the developing world. And more than anywhere else is happening in China. China is far and away the world's number one consumer of sand and of concrete.
在过去的一二十年里，中国有数亿人从农村搬到了城市。记住，当然，城市是由混凝土建造的。那么中国的沙子是从哪里来的呢？是的，所以关于沙子的事情是，你总是想从离你实际要使用它的地方很近的地方获取它，因为沙子非常重。一立方码的沙子重量超过一吨。
Hundreds of millions of people in China have moved from the countryside into cities in the last decade or two. And remember, of course, cities are made of concrete. And so where is China's sand coming from? Yeah, so the thing with sand is you always want to get it from somewhere close to where you're going to actually use it because sand is very heavy. Kibbutk yard of sand weighs more than a ton.
所以如果你必须运送它超过几英里，成本就会急剧上升。基本上，中国的建筑商和其他地方的建筑商总是在寻找附近的沙子。比如想想上海。上海就是过去 20 年里急剧膨胀的城市之一。过去 20 年里上海建造的高层建筑比整个纽约市还要多。所以显然他们使用的是惊人数量的沙子。这一切都从哪里来？好吧，在本世纪初，他们大部分是从长江获取的。他们直接从长江河底捞取。这引发了很多问题。
So if you have to transport it more than a few miles, the cost of it goes up very quickly. So basically builders in China and everywhere else are always looking for sand that's close by. So think about Shanghai for example. Shanghai is one of these cities that has just exploded in the last 20 years. More skyscrapers have been built in Shanghai in the last 20 years than there are in all of New York City. So obviously they are using just a staggering amount of sand. Where's it all coming from? Well, for in the early part of this century, they're getting most of it from the Yangtze River. They're just scooping it right off the bottom of the Yangtze River. And that caused a lot of problems.
第一，它导致河岸直接坍塌。当你挖开河中心时，河的两侧往往会直接坍塌，随之带走农田、村庄，它以一种非常糟糕的方式阻碍了航运。它还对河流的生态系统造成了严重的破坏，任何生活在河底的东西，显然都消失了。它们的栖息地刚刚被摧毁。而且，当你把水弄得满是泥沙时，
Number one, it was causing river banks to literally collapse. When you dig out the middle of the river, the sides of the river often just collapse, taking with it agricultural land, villages, it snarls up shipping in a really terrible way. And it also does serious damage to the river's ecosystem, anything that was living on the bottom of the river, obviously is gone. Their habitats just been destroyed. And also, when you silt up the water like that,
它会阻挡阳光照射到水下生长的植物。所以造成了巨大、巨大的破坏。然后中国当局意识到了这一点。他们觉得，哇，这对长江来说是一个严重的问题，长江是中国的极其重要的资源。它是数亿人的饮用水源、鱼类等等的来源。所以他们不得不禁止在长江采沙。因此，采沙者只好将作业推向
it blocks the sunlight from reaching plants that are growing underneath the water. So a huge, huge damage. Then the Chinese authorities realized this. They were like, whoa, this is a serious problem for the Yangtze River, which is an incredibly important resource for China. It's the source of drinking water for hundreds of millions of people, fish, et cetera, et cetera. So they had to ban sand mining on the Yangtze River. As a result, sand miners just sort of pushed their operations
上游几十英里处，来到中国最大的淡水湖。它叫鄱阳湖。所以鄱阳湖现在已经成为了世界上最大的沙子开采地。每年大约有 2.3 亿吨的沙子从这个湖里被捞出来。而现在，这当然开始产生它自己的一系列环境问题。它对那里生活的大量鱼类和鸟类造成了真正的破坏，包括长江江豚等濒危物种。所以基本上，中国从哪里获取沙子？它从任何顺手的地方获取。
a few dozen miles upstream to the biggest freshwater lake in China. It's called Lake Po Yang. So Lake Po Yang has now become the biggest sand mine in the world. It's about 230 odd million tons of sand are scooped out of this lake every year. And that now of course is starting to generate its own set of environmental problems. It's causing real damage to the many, many fish and birds that live there, including endangered species like freshwater porpoises. So basically, where does China get its sand from? It gets it from wherever it's handy.
当你对任何顺手的河流、湖泊施加这么大的压力时，不可避免地会引发问题。是的。我的意思是，这是一场向下竞次，还是我们只是快把沙子用完了？所以我们在可预见的未来不会彻底用完沙子。我们不会为了地球上最后一点微小颗粒的最后几粒沙子而争斗。但沙子上发生的事情更像是石油和天然气上发生的事情，对吧？地球上仍然有很多石油和天然气。
And when you put that much pressure on whatever river or lake or whatever is handy, it causes problems inevitably. Yeah. I mean, is this a race to the bottom or are we just going to run out of sand? So we're not going to completely run out of sand any time in the foreseeable future. We're not going to be fighting over the very last little pile of the last few grains on earth. But what's happening with sand is much more like what's happening with oil and gas, right? There's still a lot of it on the planet.
但那些容易获取的东西基本上已经被开采殆尽了。那些靠近地表、便宜且容易弄到手的资源正在日益消失。我们不得不走得更远，造成更多的破坏，才能获取剩下的资源。所以就像你在石油身上看到的那样，我们不得不做诸如水力压裂和海上石油钻探之类的事情
But the stuff that's easy to get at has been mostly tapped out. The stuff that's close to the surface and cheap and easy to get our hands on is increasingly disappearing. And we're having to go further and further and do more and more damage to get at the stuff that's left. So the same thing that you see happening with oil, where we're having to do things like fracking and offshore oil drilling
为了获取剩下的石油，沙子也发生了类似的事情。我们不得不越挖越深，造成越来越多的破坏，以获取日益减少的沙子供应。越挖越深，并造成越来越多的破坏以获取日益减少的沙子供应。除了通过采矿对土地造成的破坏之外，混凝土对地球的代价是什么？是的，所以混凝土有一些非常显著的代价。第一是碳排放。因此，制造水泥取决于你如何衡量它，要么是地球上第二大，要么是第三大二氧化碳排放
to get at the oil that's left, similar kind of thing is happening with sand. We're having to dig deeper and deeper and do more and more damage to get at the dwindling supplies of sand. deeper and deeper and do more and more damage to get at the dwindling supplies of sand. Beyond the damage that you can inflict on the land by mining the sand, what is the cost of concrete to the planet? Yeah, so concrete has some very significant costs. Number one is carbon emissions. So manufacturing cement is depending on how you measure it, either the second or the third biggest carbon dioxide admit
源，或者是地球上的温室气体排放源。所需的能量，焚烧制造水泥所需的全部石灰需要大量的能量，其次，这个过程本身会释放出大量的气体。因此，它产生的温室气体约占所有温室气体的 10% 左右是由水泥行业产生的，当然你需要水泥来制造混凝土。
or greenhouse gas admit, or on the planet. The energy that's required, it takes a lot of energy to incinerate all the lime that you need to make cement, number one, and also the process itself gives off a lot of gases. So it creates somewhere in the neighborhood of 10% of all greenhouse gases are created by the cement industry, and of course you need cement to make concrete.
所以这是第一点。第二点是，用混凝土覆盖如此多的地面，你在许多地方造成了所谓的城市热岛效应。太阳的热量被所有的混凝土吸收并保持。城市的温度可能会升高多达 10 或 15 度，仅仅因为混凝土保留了所有的热量。在一个越来越热的世界里，这显然是一个大问题。
So that's number one. Number two is that by covering so much ground with concrete, you create in a lot of places what's called the urban heat island effect. The sun's heat gets soaked up and held by all that concrete. The temperature of cities can be raised by as much as 10 or 15 degrees, just due to the fact that the concrete is retaining all of that heat. That's obviously a big problem in a world that's getting hotter all the time.
它可能产生的另一个影响是，它会使洪水恶化，因为在大多数情况下，混凝土不是多孔的，对吧？水在它上面流过。例如，在休斯敦最近的一系列洪水中发生的事情是，它使这些洪水变得更糟，因为当这些河水溢出河岸时，所有的水都倾泻进城市，而它无处可去。它只是流过城市的混凝土街道，
There's another effect that it can have, which is that it can make flooding worse, because for the most part, concrete is not porous, right? It water flows over it. So for instance, what happened in, in the last set of floods in Houston is it made those floods worse because when those rivers overflow their banks, all that water goes pouring into cities, and it has nowhere to go. It just flows through the concrete streets of the cities,
所以它真的会以一种非常严重的方式加剧洪水。我们需要用像现在这么多的混凝土来建造吗？不，绝对不需要。我的意思是，听着，我们需要混凝土，对吧？这不一样，它不像石油，对吧？那是一种我们可以用太阳能和风能等更清洁、更可持续的东西来替代的东西。
so it can really exacerbate flooding in a really serious way. Do we need to build with as much concrete as we do? No, not shell. I mean, listen, we need concrete, right? This is not, it's not analogous to oil, right? Which is something that we can actually replace with something cleaner and more sustainable with solar and wind.
混凝土是一种极好的建筑材料。它为世界上数十亿在 20、30 年前没有它的人们创造了安全、耐用的住房。这是件好事。所以我们需要混凝土。我们必须继续使用它。但是是的，我们可以少用很多。我们怎么能做到这一点呢？
Concrete is a great building material. It has created safe, durable housing for billions of people, the world over, who didn't have it 20, 30 years ago. That's to the good. So we need concrete. We've got to keep using it. But yeah, we could use a lot less of it. How could we do that?
嗯，首先，通过想方设法重组我们的生活方式，这样我们就不需要那么多的基础设施，汽车是最明显的例子。但也可以通过把东西做小。我的意思是，我刚回来，我刚刚在荷兰做了一些关于我的书的演讲。我住过的酒店房间的大小会让任何住酒店的美国人震惊。我的意思是，它们太小了。里面只能放一张床，一张单人床，一个小书桌，一个窗户，还有一个小洗手池。就是这样。对吧？在那里，我的意思是，你实际上可以在平均汽车旅馆里塞进两到三个这样的房间
Well, first of all, by figuring out ways to restructure how we live so that we don't need quite as much infrastructure, cars being the most obvious example. But also just by making things smaller. I mean, I just got back, I was just giving some talks about my book in the Netherlands. And the size of the hotel rooms that I stayed in would shock any hotel staying American. I mean, they are tiny. There's room for a bed, a single bed, and a little desk, and a window, and a little sink. And that's it. Right? There, I mean, you could literally fit two or three of these rooms in the average motel
六号房。你知道，当你第一次走进这么大面积的房间时，这有点令人震惊，但真的，谁在乎呢？我在大多数这些城镇只待了一晚上。我会进去，我会在电脑上做一点工作，去睡觉，起床，收拾行李离开。我不需要比这更多的空间，这就是全部，我不需要超出那个数量的空间。如果你想想这个国家数以百万计的酒店和汽车旅馆房间，我们可以轻松地将其中许多房间削减
six room. You know, it's kind of shocking when you first walk into a room that size, but really like, who cares? I was in most of these towns for one night. I'd go in, I'd, you know, do a little work on my computer, go to sleep, get up, pack up and leave. I didn't need more than, that's, I didn't need more than that amount of space. If you think about all the millions of hotel and motel rooms in this country, we could easily cut many of them
一半，你知道的，或者房屋。我的意思是，你知道的，美国人众所周知，我们建造巨大的房屋。我们喜欢拥有庞大、巨大且蔓延的联排住宅。顺便说一句，普通美国家庭的规模在过去几十年里几乎翻了一番。我们不需要那么大的空间。你的房子里不需要六个浴室。我们可以轻而易举地，你知道的，真的。我们可以轻松削减，你知道的，建立一个额外税收或税收激励等的系统来鼓励人们生活得
in half, you know, or houses. I mean, you know, Americans famously, we build giant houses. We love to have big, huge sprawling tracktouses. And the size of the average American home, by the way, has nearly doubled just in the last couple of decades. We don't need that much space. You don't need six bathrooms in your house. We could ease, you know, really. We could easily cut down, you know, create a system of extra taxes or tax incentives or whatever to encourage people to live
更小一些，而且我敢说我们以这种方式生活并不会感到不那么快乐，对吧？还有其他我们可以使用的材料吗？是的，这就是另一回事了。世界各地正在进行大量的研究，以寻找除沙子之外我们可以在混凝土中使用的其他材料。所以有人在考虑使用竹子、碎塑料或回收轮胎、碎轮胎，或者大麻，实际上，有一种东西，有一种叫做大麻混凝土的产品，你现在就可以买到。所有这些东西，我认为都有帮助，我认为它们都是好事。
smaller and I submit we would be no less happy living that way, right? Are there other materials we could be using? Yeah, so that's the other thing There is a lot of research going on around the world to come up with other materials that we could use in concrete rather than sand. So there are people who are looking at using bamboo or shredded plastic or recycled tires, shredded tires, or hemp, actually, there's a thing, there's a product called hemp creek, which you can actually buy right now. And all those things, I think, help, I think they're all to the good.
我认为都应该受到鼓励。但归根结底，我们使用替代材料所能走的路是有限的。因为，就像我说的，我们每年使用 50 亿吨的沙子和碎石。即使我们能用竹子替换所有的沙子，我们每年又从哪里弄来 50 亿吨的竹子呢？那会产生它自己的一系列问题。
I think they should all be encouraged. But at the end of the day, there's only so far we can go with alternative materials. Because, like I said, we use 50 billion tons of sand and gravel every year. And even if we could replace all that sand with, you know, bamboo, where are we gonna come up with 50 billion tons of bamboo every year, right? That would create its own set of problems.
对吧。我的意思是，我认为思考沙子危机的真正方式是重新构建这个问题。问题其实不是当我们用完沙子时会发生什么。问题是当我们用完沙子时会发生什么。问题是，当我们用尽所有东西时会发生什么？我们不应该只考虑我们如何解决沙子的危机。因为真的，这听起来很熟悉，对吧？我们知道我们在过度使用淡水。我们知道我们在砍伐太多的树木。
Right. I mean, I think the real way to think about the sand crisis is to kind of reframe the question. The question isn't really what's going to happen when we run out of sand. The question is what's going to happen when we run out of sand? The question is, what's going to happen when we run out of everything? We shouldn't just be thinking about how can we solve the problem of sand? Because really, it sounds familiar, right? We know that we're using too much fresh water. We know that we're cutting down too many trees.
我们知道我们从海洋中捕捞了太多的鱼类。我们知道我们在燃烧太多的化石燃料。现在海洋。我们知道我们在燃烧太多的化石燃料。现在回过头来发现我们正在使用太多的沙子。好吧，在我看来，这些并不是独立的问题。它们都是同一个问题的症状，那就是我们消费得太多了，对吧？我们在西方世界的生活方式以及我们现在出口到世界其他地方的生活方式，它消耗了太多的自然资源，而地球根本无法承受。现在，我认为我们在水资源上面对这一绝境的速度会比在沙子上更快，但归根结底这是同一个问题，那就是我们生活的方式根本不可持续。我们必须
We know we're harvesting too many fish out of the oceans. We know we're burning too much fossil fuel. Now oceans. We know we're burning too much fossil fuel. And now come to find out we're using too much sand. Well, to my mind, these are not separate problems. They're all symptoms of the same problem, which is just that we're consuming too much, right? The way that we live here in the Western world and that lifestyle that we've now exported to the rest of the world, it just consumes way too many natural resources and the planet simply can't sustain it. Now, I think we're going to hit that wall with water sooner than we're going to hit it with sand, but ultimately it's the same problem, which is just that the way that we live our lives just isn't sustainable. We have
想方设法以消耗更少资源的方式来建设我们的城市，这也就是大多数人类现在居住的地方。这是我们避免彻底灾难的唯一途径。文斯·拜泽尔的书叫《沙粒中的世界》。关于沙子的故事还有很多，我们甚至没有在这里触及，包括玻璃是如何改变文明的。这是一件大事，所以如果你喜欢这个讨论，你一定会喜欢这本书。所有建筑世界混凝土中都锁定了大量的沙子，但混凝土中也含有大量的隐性碳。我们将讨论如何量化这一点
got to find ways to build our cities, which is where most human beings now live, in ways that use fewer resources. That's the only way we're going to avoid total calamity. Vince Weiser's book is called The World in a Grain. There is so much more to the story of San that we didn't even touch on here, including how glass change civilization. That's a big deal, so if you like this discussion, you'll love the book. There's a lot of San locked up in all of the concrete in the built world, but there's also a lot of embodied carbon in concrete. We'll talk about how to quantify that
以及这之后的混凝土替代品。混凝土是建筑行业最喜欢的材料，但它是一种有问题的信仰，不仅仅是因为全球沙子危机。正如文斯·拜泽尔所指出的，混凝土也是一种碳密集度极高的材料。象征性的信仰，不仅仅是因为全球沙子危机。正如文斯·拜泽尔所指出的，混凝土也是极其碳密集的。水泥的生产是混凝土的关键成分，约占世界二氧化碳排放量的 8%。
and concrete alternatives after this. Concrete is the building industry's favorite material, but it's a problematic faith, and not only because of the global sand crisis. As Vince Buyser noted, concrete is also extremely carbon intensive. emblematic faith, and not only because of the global sand crisis. As Vince Buyser noted, concrete is also extremely carbon-intensive. The production of cement, which is the key ingredient in concrete, is responsible for about 8% of the world's CO2 emissions.
所以我们认为我们应该花节目的这一部分来谈谈我们建造的建筑对气候变化的影响，无论是用混凝土、木材还是你甚至从未听说过的新型材料制造的。为了做到这一点，我给凯特·西蒙宁打了电话。我是凯特·西蒙宁，我是一名建筑师、结构工程师，也是华盛顿大学的教员。我的研究重点是建筑材料对环境的影响。
And so we thought we'd spend this section of the program talking about the climate change impacts of the buildings we create, whether they're made of concrete or wood or some novel material you've never even heard of. And to do that, I called up Kate Simmonen. I'm Kate Simmonen, and I'm an architect and structural engineer and faculty member at the University of Washington. And my research is focused on the environmental impact of building materials.
当我们考虑建筑对环境的影响时，大多数人真正想到的是它们运营时的环境影响。运营建筑物的能源成本是你可能知道的东西，即加热建筑物、冷却建筑物和保持灯光常亮所需的能量。但凯特说，当我们考虑建筑物和气候变化时，这并不是全部。还有与材料本身相关的排放，即制造所有这些混凝土、钢材和玻璃所需的排放。工厂、钢铁厂、四处行驶的卡车，所有这些都会产生排放，这些排放被称为隐含排放。
When we think about the environmental impact of buildings, most people really do think about the environmental impact of operating them. The energy cost of operating a building is stuff you probably know, of the energy that it takes to heat the building and cool the building and keep the lights on. But Kate says that when we think about buildings and climate change, that is not the full picture. There are also the emissions associated with the materials themselves, the emissions that were required to make all that concrete and steel and glass. The factories, the steel mills, the trucks that drive around, all of those create emissions, and those emissions are termed the embodied emissions.
因此，某种程度上内嵌在材料中的排放，尽管它们实际上是制造材料时发生的排放。这些排放被称为隐含碳。创造我们周围建筑环境所需的碳排放。凯特在华盛顿大学领导着碳领导力论坛。这是一个由建筑师、设计师和学者组成的致力于减少隐含碳的组织。她表示，新材料和更环保的制造对未来很重要，但我们为了减少隐含碳可以做的第一件事就是继续使用这些建筑物
So the emissions that are sort of embodied in the materials, although they're really the emissions that happened when making the materials. These emissions are known as embodied carbon. The carbon emissions that were needed to create the built environment all around us. Kate heads up the carbon leadership forum at the University of Washington. It's a group of builders and designers and academics working to reduce embodied carbon. And she says that new materials and greener manufacturing are important for the future, but the first thing we can do to reduce embodied carbon is just to keep using the buildings
我们已经建造的。如果我们能保留我们拥有的东西，那是减少隐含碳的第一个最佳步骤。因此，翻新建筑物和维护它们是关键。我们在混凝土上投入了大量资金。因此，当我们选择制造新事物以及维护和保留我们拥有的东西时，让我们做出正确的选择。即便如此，我们知道未来几十年将会迎来建设热潮。我们需要住房、新的绿色、能源基础设施、新的交通，如果所有这些结构
we've already built. If we can keep what we have, that's the first best step to reducing embodied carbon. So renovating buildings and maintaining them is key. We've invested a lot in that concrete. And so let's make our choices correctly when we choose to make new things and maintain and keep the things that we have. But even so, we know there's going to be a building boom in the coming decades. We need to housing, new green, energy, infrastructure, new transportation, and if all those structures
都是用传统的钢铁和混凝土制造的，这对气候来说将是一个问题。但凯特说，如今有很多潜在的低碳建筑材料，包括替代混凝土和低碳钢。还有令人兴奋的新技术，它们可以通过捕获大气中或烟囱处的碳并将其转化回石灰石来培育岩石。因此，如果我们谈论碳捕获和储存，想想碳捕获并利用该碳来建造建筑物，这样我们就可以把这些岩石变成建筑物。这种碳捕获技术距离成为现实还有很长的路要走。但其中最主要的
are being made using traditional steel and concrete, it is going to be a problem for the climate. But Kate says there are a lot of potential low carbon building materials out there these days, including alternative concretes and low carbon steel. And there's exciting new technologies that are growing rocks by capturing carbon from the atmosphere or at smoke stacks and turning it back into limestone. So that if we talk about carbon capture and storage, think about carbon capture in using that carbon to build buildings with so we could take those rocks and turn them into buildings. That kind of carbon capture technology is a long way from becoming a reality. But one of the most
正在使用传统的钢铁和混凝土建造，这对气候来说将是一个问题。但凯特表示，如今有很多潜在的低碳建筑材料，包括新型混凝土和低碳钢。还有令人兴奋的新技术，它们通过捕捉大气中或烟囱里的碳来“生长”岩石，并将其变回石灰石。因此，如果我们讨论碳捕获与封存，可以想想碳捕获并利用这些碳来建造建筑物，这样我们就可以把这些岩石变成建筑物。这种碳捕获技术距离成为现实还有很长的路要走。但其中最重要的一项
promising green building materials that people are using right now is actually one of the oldest building materials on Earth, wood. A wooden building stores carbon within it, and so if you can build with more wood instead of concrete, you have the potential to dramatically reduce the embodied carbon emissions. You could potentially even have a building that is a net carbon negative, and with that goal in mind, architects and engineers are developing large, manufactured wood products that they call Mass Timber. So, Mass Timber is a term that defines wood buildings that are made out of large pieces of wood,
有前景的绿色建筑材料，人们现在正在使用它，其实它是地球上最古老的建筑材料之一，也就是木材。一座木造建筑可以在其中储存碳，因此，如果你能用更多的木材而不是混凝土来建造，你就有潜力大幅减少隐含碳排放。你甚至有可能建造一座碳负排放的建筑，带着这个目标，建筑师和工程师正在开发大型的、预制的木制品，他们称之为重型木材（Mass Timber）。所以，重型木材是一个定义由大块木材制成的木结构建筑的术语，
so massive pieces of wood. You make Mass Timber products by layering sheets of wood on top of one another and then compressing them to create extremely strong, prefabricated wood panels that can be assembled into all kinds of structures. Architects are beginning to experiment with using mass timber to build anything from skyscrapers to bridges. And the advantage of mass timber is that the thick pieces of wood have an inherent fire resistant characteristic to them. So imagine if you're trying to build a campfire and you make it out of little small sticks, they all burn up and you get a pile of ash. But if you start with really big pieces of wood, and then you fall asleep and let the fire burn itself
也就是大块的木材。制造重型木材产品的方法是将一层层的木板叠放在一起，然后进行压缩，从而创造出极其坚固的预制木板，这些木板可以组装成各种结构。建筑师们开始尝试使用重型木材建造从摩天大楼到桥梁的各种建筑。重型木材的优势在于，厚厚的木头具有天然的防火特性。所以想象一下，如果你想生篝火，却用细小的树枝来搭，它们全都会烧尽，你会得到一堆灰烬。但如果你从非常大的木块开始，然后你睡着了，任由火自己烧，
out, you come back and you still have a log in your fireplace. So that's the same thing that happens with buildings, with a heavy timber building, it sort of almost puts itself out. I mean, how skyscraper behaves in fire is one thing, but it feels strange to think about skyscrapers made of wood at all, you know, like in a modern age. Well, why is anything weird? Yes, I guess. Things are just weird because we haven't heard of them. If you went back 150 years, nobody would have heard of a steel building.
出来后，你会发现你的壁炉里仍然有一根原木。建筑物也是同样的道理，对于一座重型木结构建筑来说，它几乎能自动熄灭。我的意思是，摩天大楼在火灾中的表现是一回事，但一想到摩天大楼竟然是用木头建造的，在现代社会总觉得有点奇怪。好吧，为什么什么东西都会觉得奇怪？是的，我想是的。事物之所以奇怪，只是因为我们没听说过它们。如果你回到150年前，没有人听说过钢结构建筑。
Right. And they were worried about cast iron. So they were cast iron buildings and cast iron melted and people were very concerned about it. So if you, you know, if you look back in time, there's been massive innovations about what we do. And if you look back in time, there's been massively large tall wood buildings that have built and lasted a long period of time. Yeah. all wood buildings that have built and lasted a long period of time. So we learn a trade that is handed down to us from other people. So a lot of what we learn, we've been told of what works. And so we have confidence in things because they've been done before.
没错。而且他们当时还担心铸铁。所以当时有铸铁建筑，而铸铁会融化，人们对此非常担忧。所以如果你回顾过去，就会发现我们在做的事情经历过巨大的创新。如果你回顾过去，就会发现以前建造过规模巨大、高耸的木结构建筑，并且历经了很长时间依然完好。是的，所有这些木结构建筑都曾被建造并持续了很长一段时间。所以我们学习了一门由其他人代代相传的手艺。因此，我们学到的很多东西，都是别人告诉我们什么可行。我们之所以对某些事情有信心，是因为过去有人做过。
So I don't think it's unreasonable to be a little conservative. I mean, we wouldn't want to build a high-rise building that burns and kills lots of people, nor would we want to build a building that wasn't able to maintain over a long period of time. You know, if I step back and think, if my driver is climate change, and my driver is climate change, in order to have the building sector be part of the climate solution, we're going to have to take some risks. And so one of the risks will be trying novel materials and new methods of using those materials to drive to a market where we have carbon negative buildings. Cities full of carbon negative wooden skyscrapers is definitely an attractive vision. And Kate says that wooden buildings have the potential to be carbon negative,
所以我认为保持一点保守并非不合理。我的意思是，我们既不想建造一栋会燃烧并导致许多人死亡的高层建筑，也不想建造一栋无法长期维护的建筑。你知道，如果我退一步思考，如果我的驱动因素是气候变化，为了让建筑业成为气候解决方案的一部分，我们将不得不承担一些风险。因此，其中一个风险将是尝试新颖的材料以及使用这些材料的新方法，从而推动市场迈向拥有碳负排放建筑的时代。充满碳负木质摩天大楼的城市绝对是一个迷人的愿景。凯特说，木结构建筑具有成为碳负排放的潜力，
but it's not that straightforward. You have to really analyze every aspect of the supply chain before you can make such a declaration. One of the most important things to consider is where that wood is coming from. Because the forest itself is pulling carbon out of the atmosphere and if you take wood out of the forest, you're changing the forest carbon balance. So in order for wood to be a great building material for the climate, you have to make sure that it's being harvested sustainably. And with wood products, we need to be careful
但这并非那么简单。在做出这样的宣告之前，你必须真正分析供应链的各个方面。最需要考虑的事情之一就是这些木材的来源。因为森林本身就在从大气中吸收碳，如果你把木材从森林中砍伐出来，就会改变森林的碳平衡。因此，要让木材成为对气候友好的优质建筑材料，你必须确保它是以可持续的方式采伐的。对于木制品，我们需要小心，
that we don't set up a system that incentivize wasting wood and chopping down forests and not replanting them. Kate Simmonin says that Mass-Temper isn't a perfect building material. There is no perfect building material. But building stuff always involved difficult choices and trade-offs, and it's Kate's goal to make sure that architects and builders are considering embodied carbon when they make
不要建立一个会激励人们浪费木材、砍伐森林却不进行重植的系统。凯特·西莫宁（Kate Simmonin）表示，重型木材并非完美的建筑材料。世界上没有完美的建筑材料。但建造东西总是伴随着艰难的选择和权衡，凯特的目标是确保建筑师和建造商在决定建造什么以及如何建造时考虑到隐含碳，因为我们所有人都将与这些后果共存。
their decisions about what to build and how to build it, because we're all going to be living with the consequences. Embodied carbon is up front. These are the emissions that happen when we build things now. We're going to be building a new New York every month until 2050. Across the world, those emissions are huge, and if we don't figure out how to address them, we're not going to meet climate targets. So more and more people are recognizing that, looking for strategies to figure out how to reduce and drive the market to low-carbon solutions.
隐含碳是首当其冲的。这些是在我们现在建造东西时产生的排放。从现在到2050年，我们每个月都要建造一个新的纽约。在世界各地，这些排放量是巨大的，如果我们不弄清楚如何解决它们，我们将无法达成气候目标。因此，越来越多的人意识到了这一点，并在寻找策略，以弄清楚如何减少碳排放并推动市场走向低碳解决方案。
99% Invisible's impact design coverage is funded in part by Autodesk. Autodesk supports the design and creation of innovative solutions to the world's most pressing social and environmental challenges, including technologies to anticipate and respond to challenges facing the construction industry. Autodesk is a proud partner of EC3, the embodied carbon calculator for construction. EC3 is a free, open-source tool to help design and construction professionals make climate smart choices about what materials to use in construction. Depending on how it was made, one steel beam may have much lower embodied carbon than another one that looks and performs the same. EC3 reveals the embodied carbon of the materials going into our buildings, empowering architects, engineers, and contractors to make informed choices, selecting the materials that have the lowest environmental impact,
99% Invisible 的影响力设计报道部分由 Autodesk 赞助。Autodesk 支持设计和创造创新解决方案，以应对世界上最紧迫的社会和环境挑战，包括用于预测和应对建筑行业所面临挑战的技术。Autodesk 是 EC3（建筑隐含碳计算器）的自豪合作伙伴。EC3 是一个免费的开源工具，可帮助设计和施工专业人员在选择建筑材料时做出气候明智的选择。根据制造方式的不同，一根钢梁的隐含碳可能比另一根外观和性能相同的钢梁要低得多。EC3 揭示了进入我们建筑的材料的隐含碳，赋能建筑师、工程师和承包商做出明智的选择，选择对环境影响最小的材料，
and providing transparency for a more sustainable built environment. To learn more and check out EC3 for yourself, you can visit buildingtransparency.org or go to autodesk.redshift.com to explore more on the future of making. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald, music by Sean Real. Katie Mingle is the senior producer Kurt Kurt Colstad is the digital director. The rest of the team includes senior editor Delaney Hall, Sheree Fusif, Avery Trouffman, Vivian Lee, Sophia Klatsker, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California.
并为更可持续的建筑环境提供透明度。要了解更多信息并亲自体验 EC3，您可以访问 buildingtransparency.org，或者访问 autodesk.redshift.com，探索更多关于制造未来的内容。本周的 99% Invisible 由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）制作，肖恩·里尔（Sean Real）配乐。凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）是高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Colstad）是数字总监。团队其他成员包括高级编辑德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、谢里·福西夫（Sheree Fusif）、埃弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Trouffman）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Lee）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心电台街。
99% Invisible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows and all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org, or on Instagram and Reddit too. But the concrete foundation of 99PI is 99PI.org. Radio Topeia. From PRX.
99% Invisible 是 PRX 旗下 RadioTopia 的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的坚定独立的集合。您可以在 radiotopia.fm 找到所有这些节目。您可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并参与关于节目的讨论。您可以在 Twitter 上 @ 我（Roman Mars），也可以 @ 节目（@99PI org），或者在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上关注我们。但 99PI 的混凝土基础是 99PI.org。RadioTopia，来自 PRX。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您 本期节目尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。